Hello Freak bitches we're going to do now.
Um,
this is, this is my single off my new
record that comes out on your birthday.
August 11 called ghost in my bed.
MMM.
There's a music video out
for it now if anyone wants,
where does someone get that? Can you get
to youtube? Is that okay? It's on youtube.
Youtube and uh, coincidentally it
is kcrws toone of the day today.
Oh, I don't even know how
that's possible. Well,
it's a little loud. Okay. I'm going
to tune it up like a real profession.
Tune up with your phone.
No. Yeah. Really? Yes.
Joseph, they have these things
that did the instruments.
What is it on your phone? Like
I'm, I'm totally ignorant to this
microphone.
Get distracting frequency,
right?
What is it called? It's just an APP.
It's a guitar to just hundreds of them.
Oh Wow. There's a bunch of them. Huh?
Here. What are you singing right now? Wow.
And it works off of the microphone on
your phone the same way one would work
like in a studio sonically and pretty
good. It could be in a better situation.
Should I give it another angle?
No, that's fine. That's fine. Okay.
You want to do this?
Oh wait, should I get my pick or
should I go fingers? You get your pig.
You hit your peak. Like a
real pig with you counseling.
Cause I'm playing all fingers. These
their shirts. Right. What's that?
It might be one. Oh, there are fun.
Yeah. Then get, yeah. Are you sure?
I'm just kind of picks bro them.
Oh
God.
Stop it.
Boozy amaze me Tom.
Thanks.
It's so funny.
Oh,
long child.
Wow.
Eh,
Leo
keys.
Oh,
it was me,
my chest
Da Dad.
Cause he
always gets me
from a star
Kcrw song.
That was awesome. Thanks. My
pleasure. Jane. Here's the shit.
I took my headphones off. I hope I didn't
ruin the Howells. Awesome. Beautiful.
Sorry. Perfect. Don't say a word here.
Okay.